[Music]
are you looking to simplify your policy
controls while simultaneously making
them more specific
in a previous video we discussed policy
controls for certificate authority
service and focused on course-grained or
issuance policies that are used to
create the baseline for a ca pool
in this video we'll dive into the other
side of policy controls with
fine-grained policies using templates
templates allow for defining a set of
policy controls that are not tied to a
single ca pool
for example to standardize the issuance
of server tls certificates across all ca
pools in an organization
or to apply multiple policies to a
single ca pool
one application of this is for applying
policies at more granular levels such as
per user many solutions today don't
discriminate between fine grained and
coarse grain controls which means that
every department or service that needs a
certificate has to use the issuance
policy that has been assigned to the
whole company or service that works if
you have high level policy needs but
what about when you need a seamless way
to create more detailed policies without
needing multiple scoped cas
that's where fine-grained policies come
in
policy controls can be considered
fine-grained if they are built using
templates and are applied to specific
users through a ca pool's iam policy
these templates determine the operations
a particular user can perform on a ca
pool and can be useful in situations
when you need to restrict the kinds of
certificates that different individuals
can issue
think of this as a way to segment based
on conditions and user groups
thanks to iam conditions enforcing the
templates you can get specific and say
that anthony can issue from the ca pool
with template a and bucola can issue
from the same ca pool but with input b
and not template a
this makes it easy to give the correct
access to users with less risk and
allows for scaling of your policies
across lots of users with less
certificates needed
to use a certificate template you'll
need the ca service certificate template
user role on the template
google recommends that the authors of a
certificate template grant the ca
service certificate template user role
to all members in the organization
who might use that certificate template
note that this doesn't allow all
organization members to use the template
with just any pool
individuals still need to be granted
access to specific ca pools in addition
to the permission to use the template to
create a template you can use this
gcloud command to configure your
policies quickly setting the template id
allowed x.509 extensions subjects and
predefined values
cis provides a list of certificate
profiles which are common combinations
of certificate extension values for
common use cases
you can use these profiles as
inspiration for what to put in the
templates you create
check out the link in the description to
see the examples
if you want to add specific extensions
to all certificates issued using this
template you'll need to create a yaml
file containing those extensions
this is the file referred to in the
predefined values file line of the code
then you'll need to do two things to use
the template
first you'll need to configure the ca
pool to require that the user used that
new template otherwise the user can just
choose not to use it and can still
request any certificate they want
and second adjust the certificate
requests that the user makes to actually
reference that template i'll link the
tutorials on how to complete these steps
in the description to learn more about
creating different templates for
certificate authority service and other
useful documents check the links below
if you've been enjoying the cas series
make sure to like this video and
subscribe to be notified of more thanks
for watching
[Music]